l'un des grands objectifs du président
américain est en train de prendre forme
celui du retrait des troupes américaines
en afghanistan
les etats-unis ont quasiment rapatrier
leurs contingents déployés dans ce pays
d'asie centrale
des milliers de soldats ont regagné
leurs foyers ces derniers mois désormais
washington espère atteindre le seuil des
8000 600 militaires présents sur place
dans les prochains jours le président
donald trump à expliciter les raisons de
ce retrait nous sommes là depuis dix
neuf ans nous n'agissons pas vraiment
comme des soldats nous agissons en tant
que policier et nous ne sommes pas
envoyé là bas pour être des policiers
mais nous sommes là depuis 19 ans et oui
je pense que c'est suffisant et ils
comprennent
nous avons des discussions très
positives nous voulons ramener nos
soldats à la maison
nous voulons les ramener à la maison et
nous ne parlons pas seulement de là bas
nous parlons aussi d'autres pays
nous ramenons nos soldats chez eux nous
pouvons toujours y retourner si nous
devons y retourne et nous y retournerons
et nous y retournerons en furie et
ensuite nous y retournerons en tant que
guerrier en tant que combattant mais
pour l'instant et nous sommes des
policiers et nous ne sommes pas censés
être une force de police
nous sommes censés être une force de
combat un projet qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre de l'accord signé entre les
talibans les états unis en février
dernier plusieurs trêves de combat ont
été amorcées avant que les deux parties
ne parviennent à trouver un terrain
d'entente
d'après un responsable américain qui
souhaite préserver l'anonymat
la crise sanitaire mondiale aurait
accéléré les choses en raison des
préoccupations liées aux qu'ovide 19
nous avons entamé ce retrait plus
rapidement que prévu depuis la signature
de cet accord historique
les taliban ont promis qu'il ne
permettrait pas d organisation
djihadiste d'opérer sur le sol afghan
une manière de calmer le jeu alors qu'il
n'aurait en réalité qu'un seul objectif
chasser la classe politique actuel pour
s'emparer du pouvoir
[Musique]